je trouve que c'est une très bonne
organisation parce que la première fois
dans le premier tour ça a été une
catastrophe on complète et dont l'âge
est quoi ils ont pris conscience du
danger puisque c'est vrai danger est là
et c'est pas fini encore mais là je vois
qu'aujourd'hui dont j'y suis allé voter
dans de bonnes conditions
la dont il ya rien à dire la préparation
de la mairie a été exemplaire tout s'est
bien passé
hygiène impeccable circulation aussi ils
ont bien pris soin de de faire entrer
les gens dans des endroits et de le
faire ressortir par l'autre on touche
quasiment rien s'est désinfecté la
petite corbeille pour mettre la carte
d'électeur et désinfecter lui on est
désinfecté non c'est impeccable le
premier de ne pas déjà existé volé le
départ de tout annuler parce que vous
avez des gens était malade et où elles
sont obligés de voter à la sortie voyez
ça ça c'est quand même assez mal passé
moyens pour ça que ma maladie
aujourd'hui faire ça en septembre ou un
peu plus tard vrai